informe de 116 páginas que condena a
marine lepén la oficina antifraude de la
unión europea le pide que devuelva casi
137 mil euros que presuntamente malversó
cuando era eurodiputada entre 2004 y
2017 mediapart que tuvo acceso al
informe público estas acusaciones un
golpe político que denuncia también
acercarnos a la candidata de
suriman indepen niega absolutamente los
hechos le pen no tuvo acceso a ningún
documento en cambio mediapart si es
importante recordar que media parte
apoyó a jean-luc mélenchon se llama
simplemente cortinas de humo superior en
el objetivo del informe otros tres
diputados jean marie le pen
y me salió entonces compañero de marín
le pen y bruno gollnisch en total el
partido está acusado de malversar 617
mil euros
según mediapart el dinero europeo se usó
para fines políticos nacionales en 2018
la candidata euroescéptica ya había sido
investigada por malversación de fondos
públicos en el caso de los asistentes
parlamentarios europeos al menos 27.000
se habrían utilizado para comprar
artículos promocionales y botellas de
vino para el congreso de agrupación
nacional en lyon en 2014